you [ __ ] with the psychedelics
yeah yeah for sure acid as acid
mushrooms
what is i've never done acid i heard
it's like more like extremely visual
um yeah i feel like so it lasts a good
bit longer than mushrooms
your high is probably twice as long the
trip
right i feel like sometimes with
mushrooms you could kind of get into
like a
a dark spot in the trip yeah where
you're like facing these
these demons or whatever you've been
running right right right and then you
you know usually come out the other side
of
a better person for it right um with
acid like you always know it's the drugs
you know
like you'll start tweaking like oh it's
the drugs i bet [ __ ] it
on to the next yeah mushrooms are having
like question your whole life's purpose
you take too much there's some moments
where you really have to look yourself
in the mirror
um acid is more like i'm gonna take some
acid i'm gonna have to
you can go to the bar yeah i'm saying
you go to the bar you can go around
strangers i can have a full like
intellectual ass convo with a random
stranger on that so on mushrooms i kind
of just want to be with like my core
group
for sure yeah and i had a bad trip when
uh i was in texas
tripping the [ __ ] out man i went i
decided to go bar hopping after i ate a
whole bunch of shrooms and an edible
yeah you bold worst decision in my life
you bought your boat
i was freaking the [ __ ] out i was about
to start looking at people in the bar
like a stew face door something crazy no
there was a lady
dancing and her face looked like you
remember on cops back in the day they
used to have their faces scrambled yeah
yeah
and there was this [ __ ] dancing in
front of us
and uh i was with uh i was with freddie
gibbs and i was like yo fred is
is that [ __ ] we were both on shrooms
i was like
is do you see her face and he's like we
see we saw the same thing he's like nah
it's all [ __ ] up
bro and then some dudes came in i was
paranoid as [ __ ] bro i thought so bro i
was
i was it was a bad look that [ __ ] i'm
never doing shrooms ever again in like a
social
area and ain't that but you could do
acid you could do fine yup